but otherwise, the vectors
are defined in a similar way.
We read this as bra a, I'm not sure if that's
supposed to be funny, but the idea is that the names bra and ket
are two halves of the word bracket, and we'll have more to say
about that in just a moment.
But first, let's take a look
at a very quick example.
For the binary alphabet, we have that bra zero is
this row vector right here analogous to ket a,
except it's a row vector
instead of a column vector and bra one is this vector right here.
Now in general, if we multiply a row
vector to a column vector, just thinking about these as matrices
that happen to have just
one row or just one column, then we get a one by one matrix, which we can think
about as being a scaler.
Here, by the way, you should
think about these stars as representing arbitrary numbers.
In particular, if we
multiply the row vector bra a to the column vector ket b,
then there are two things that can happen.
One is that a and b are equal, so they're the same classical state, in which case, the ones will line up
and the product will be equal to one or it could be the case
the a and b are different,
and so the ones don't line up and the product is equal to zero.
A simple way of expressing
these observations is like this right here.
And just to keep things tidy, we write this product like this with just one bar in the middle and it means exactly the same
thing as this right here.
And now you can see how the
bra and the ket go together to form a bracket, which is
also called an inner product,
and that's something
that's quite important that we'll come back to
in lesson number three.
Multiplying a column
vector to a row vector, on the other hand, gives us a matrix as you can see right here.
So for example, going back yet
again to the binary alphabet, if we multiply ket zero to bra zero,
what we get is this matrix right here, and we can go through
the other possibilities to see what happens.
Ket zero times bra one gives
us this matrix right here where the one has now moved
over to this position.
Ket one, bra zero looks like this and here's ket one, bra one.
What we see happening is that there is just a single one in a matrix that's otherwise all zeros, and the position of that one
is determined by which
classical states we choose in the bra and the ket.
More precisely, and
this is true in general, for any choice of a classical state set, the matrix that we get by
multiplying ket a to bra b
is the matrix with a one in the a, b entry and a zero for all other entries.
And now that we have both the
first and the second parts of the Dirac notation, we have a very handy tool for connecting operations with matrices.
So let's go back briefly
to deterministic operations and recall that a bit
earlier in the lesson,
it was stated that for every function f of
this form right here, we have a deterministic operation that transforms a into f of a
for each possible classical state a. And we said that for
any function like this, there's always a unique
matrix M that acts like this
on standard basis states.
Using the Dirac notation, we can now very easily express this matrix like you see right here,
and we can see how sometimes
it's possible to work with matrices entirely
within the framework of the Dirac notation
without ever explicitly converting
to vectors and matrices, meaning rectangles filled with numbers.
In this case, we can check that the
required formula is true by multiplying M to ket a.
We substitute our
expression for M like this and we can remove the parenthesis and snap together the bra
b with a ket a like this.
And that's because matrix
multiplication is linear, in this case, in the first argument and it's associated so we can remove the parentheses.
And now, recalling that we have a fixed a that we're talking about as we sum over all of the
possible choices of b,
this bracket right here is
always gonna be equal to zero when b is not equal to a, so there won't be any
contribution to the sum,
and when b is equal to a, the bracket will be equal to one and so we'll be left with
this one term right here.
That's the formula we wanted and so we have a very nice and simple way of expressing a function as a matrix.
In addition to deterministic operations, we also have operations that
themselves introduce randomness or uncertainty about the
classical state of a system.
We use the term probabilistic operation to mean operations like this, and to be precise, when we say probabilistic operation,
we mean operations that
might introduce randomness, so deterministic operations are actually a special case
of probabilistic operations
that just don't happen to
introduce any randomness.
Here's a simple example where
some randomness is introduced.
This is an operation on a single bit. The way that it works is that if the classical state
of the bit is a zero,
then nothing happens. The bit stays as a zero, but if the classical
state of the bit is a one, then the operation flips the bit to zero